downstairs I'll tell you a scary story I
swear this girl I've told this story so
many times this girl um I knew in
college right and she was like a sweet
girl next door she was dating a guy our
senior year and he had bought her a
house yeah so he like they moved
together I mean they had lived in a
house together had a whole family and I
was at um they called them like dirties
like day parties you know like like it
was first St Patrick's Day okay okay and
I go into the the basement at the time
and she walks out and and he the the
boyfriend she had at the time was coming
to the party but he wasn't there yet and
she walks out of the bathroom with a
dude that she dated freshman year and he
like cheated on her they like you're
only together like a month he cheated on
it like he was he was crazy like he was
trying to and she went back to him well
I mean she's still with the guy from
college to this day